[Music]
you know it's been nearly 25 years since
the Power Rangers became a worldwide
sensation but the franchise is getting a
big screen reboot with Bryan Cranston
and Elizabeth Banks and beyond lines
Ashley crossing was first on the set to
discover that Bryan has a history with
the Rangers I got a job
dubbing some of the dialogue from
Japanese into English I always did the
the monsters thing you will not escape
me you know that kind of thing
that was sure a long time ago
Bryan was paid fifty bucks an hour for
that voice-over work and now he's back
in the five billion dollar Power Rangers
franchise playing Zord on the group's
boss you five are the Power Rangers
Elizabeth Banks plays the villain Rita
Repulsa she endured four and a half
hours of makeup face prosthetics fake
gold teeth and a stretchy green bodysuit
just to achieve this kind of evil sexy
look crazy headdress crazy outfits big
and broad and brassy and ballsy and
takes no prisoners
I've killed brain just before et was on
the vancouver set to meet the five up
and comers playing the Power Rangers
you're doing stunts you're in Walter
you're here you're there you're doing
everything so it's like you need to be
strong the Red Ranger de coeur
Montgomery who's got a little Zac Efron
vibe going on transformed his body to
play the leader of the pack it was like
a full-time job you go and you try and
you come home and eat and sleep and then
you train again three times a day every
day and I loved it while we were there
we also spoke to Becky gee she plays the
yellow Power Ranger and up she's also a
singer a rapper she's actually been on
Empire and she also got Jennifer Lopez
to appear in this music video that is
more than 60 million views on YouTube
why JLo well because the song is called
Becky on the block